back here on the Rich Eisen show how you
doing Charles I'm doing great rich I
hope you and everyone there's doing
fantastic hope your Thanksgiving was
wonderful right it certainly was it
certainly was right back at you what
what game you doing this week we're
getting this minute Minnesota at Atlanta
man you've been listening that is it
that is a fantastic game you've been
doing a lot of Vikings games lately
Charles V this will be our third yeah
what do you see from this team that
makes you think they're Super Bowl
worthy ready ready to go in the past
it's all been defense defense defense
offense don't screw it up as you might
expect from a defensive minded head
coach like Mike Zimmer I remember two
years ago doing games with him and Mike
telling me I want 21 points 21 points
and we went 21 points if we went defense
centric deal okay great
there's still a defensive centric team
but this offense can score and has been
scoring and I think that the bottom line
is at some point they've got to just be
all in and by indicates Keenum and just
let this bad boy go because he's
operating really well cases right now as
you know rich he's the guy that when you
go to the party and give me a great case
you say hello to him
people are looking over case his
shoulder to see who else there is to
talk to there's got to be somewhat
better here to talk to him but instead
he's really that guy you should shake
his hand and spend some time with it
because that offense is humming right
now because the last four weeks the
defense hasn't had to be as on point
because they're putting up big points on
the offensive end to give keenham a lot
of that credit well I mean I had him on
the show yesterday Charles and I asked
him did does he want to hear from Mike
Zimmer that he's the guy and is he
playing football like he's looking over
his shoulder and he basically said no
that I feel like I'm I prove myself
every single time out that that's the
way this business is he even turned the
tables on me he goes do you look over
your shoulder when you're a broadcasting
every day you know I kind of found that
answer I love that answer that's the
answer you want to hear I guess it's a
great answer and I would tell Kate that
I look over my shoulder every day and
that's part of what fuels me so it's
part of is it's just a matter how you go
about it but actually wrote down in my
notes getting ready for a Minnesota game
a couple weeks ago that two cases point
without him without me having heard that
out of his mouth
I wrote down in my notes rich Case
Keenum plays like he's not worried about
anyone cake taking his job he does not
play like a backup trying to keep the
job he plays like a starter who knows
it's his job and that's really unusual
for a guy in his position so what he
told you I think that that verifies
exactly what he's talked about what he
what he's doing I don't care what Mike
Zimmer says I just go out and play and
and it's so great I mean I mentioned you
yesterday I might as well talk about it
with you here certainly since you'll
probably be calling some of these games
throughout the month of December on Fox
the NFC is right there man it's
unbelievable because the Vikings when
they're done with Atlanta they played
Carolina which plays the Saints and
after they're done playing Carolina the
Saints play the Falcons on NFL Network
and then you've got the Rams in Arizona
they take on the Eagles after the Eagles
take on the Seahawks who take on the
Rams after the Rams are done with the
Eagles I mean it's gonna all come out in
the wash year in the next two to three
weeks that it is and it's so much fun
and to me last weekend that Rams New
Orleans game was so much fun to target
as one to watch but what I came away
from it was going into it after what
happened to the Rams in Minnesota okay
what this team
there's figuring out how to win and
getting comfortable with their status
when they get off the deck and have that
kind of performance at home and they did
this is really impressive what's going
on in Los Angeles now with Shaun McBay
Wade Phillips running the defense and
that team playing the way that they're
playing Jared Goff right on down the
line because that Minnesota game was a
bruising tough emotional affair people
look at the final score rich they see
24/7
it was 7-7 in the fourth quarter and he
remembered jagoff hit Cooper come with
that pass that would have taken him to
the one-yard line and they could have
gone in up they could have you know been
ahead in the fourth quarter and he got
hit fumble
in Minnesota took over and really never
looked back but that was a tough game
for them to bounce back from emotionally
and they did it they did it with style
and then just golf versus once on the
same field right yeah or two or it means
so much could mean it you know it means
it's it's kind of neat you know I'm kind
of bummed that the league decided to
just go with the same old matchup like
Raven stealers instead of like maybe
turning the page here this is this is a
new fangled situation and I understand
the green base not in it Dallas isn't in
it and that might suppress some ratings
but do you think that this is a changing
of the guard away here in the NFL I
think it's one where we're introducing
that new guard you know it's not a total
change yet because Aaron Rodgers is
going to work his way back and I think
he's far from being done but I do think
that just off of last year and rich you
know history tells us that when you
draft quarterbacks that high in the
draft they're paired together for life
right and at the end of last year the
narrative the narrative was very simply
when's looks like he's going to be a
player Goff looks like a bust and now
we've got two guys neither one of them's
any close to a bus both of them planted
a really high level of power in their
teams and now we have two that'll be
linked we're thinking for the next 10 to
12 years a big-time play so every time
we lament about the top quarterbacks
retiring going out Peyton Manning's
retired when will Tom Brady go
how long can Drew Brees play oh yeah
that's right here comes went here comes
Goff dak Prescott struggling now but
he's a guy that you would identify as on
the rise the game keeps turning itself
over even we think that it won't and
that's why that matchup is so compelling
especially considering what Goff went
through last year were frankly he had no
chance in that situation that Los
Angeles had last year yeah and then you
go Bay and what they do mean now he has
an opportunity to be a good player he
had no shot West yeah and yeah Matt Ryan
who is gonna be right there in front of
you this week on Fox Charles Davis Kevin
Burkhardt with the call of Vikings and
Falcons and obviously Cam and Russell
Wilson you know things are that there
are a new millennium a bunch of
quarterbacks obviously in a league where
where you still can't fill out 32 spots
for starters I do want I would be remiss
if I didn't ask you about Tennessee
Charles putting yeah Alan to your hat on
what is what I speak on behalf of the
volunteer alumni base here certainly
somebody played for this team what do
you think this Tennessee need to do
right now that is the whatever a million
dollar question you want to ask rich
they made a decision as an
administration to hire Greg Schiano so
let me touch that real quick
obviously the fan base wasn't real
excited and I feel like a lot of the fan
base brought in Penn State to buttress
their argument but the main thing was
they didn't get him
what stems from all that in my opinion
from the outside looking in and this is
no aspersions on the administration
there but it's something that I would
have told them you've got to settle -
Jon Gruden question because John was the
people's choice yet again and
understandably so and what I mean by
settling at rich is if you don't
approach John and get a definitive
answer one way or the other or just even
announce that he's not you're not going
in that direction your fan base still
thinks that he might be a possibility so
no matter who you hire otherwise that's
a thud we went through in Florida went
through a years ago Melanie Howard Ron's
look the problem was they went they
visited with Bob Stoops and Mike
Shanahan first in the Howard Ron's look
at the floor two people lost their mind
this is a similar situation in Knoxville
now they're talking about finding a
Tennessee guy bringing someone home
doing it that way the problem is is
there's no obvious guy if T Martin is
that guy I'm all behind it I love t but
he hasn't been a head coach and I think
that's part of the hesitancy of the
administration right now we're in a
situation now where they really wanted a
sitting head coach who's been there done
it before and we have a team that's not
very tough right now and I think that's
what the appeal was with Schiano so if
people think okay well shallows record
wasn't good it wasn't it wasn't that and
a lot of ways he was exactly what our
program needed now make the move and
face it bridge you know this
anyone what coach really is going to
look at our job now and say well that's
the place for me right now because the
administration made a decision there's a
howl of protest that rescinded the
decision are they gonna be there for me
when I need them it's a legitimate
question that each candidates going to
ask that's why to me it shouldn't matter
if T Martin's been a head coach
somewhere before he's been part of
big-time program football he's been a
coach he knows what it's like to
coordinate offenses in big-time schools
give him a shot he wanted a choice
Charles and I would I would jump in
wholeheartedly and support him as much
as we can remember we also have Casey
Rodgers as a defensive coordinator
within New York Jets he would be someone
that we should take a good hard look at
is having Tennessee ties you know
Phillip Fulmer is still around the
program coach Fulmer still there he's
advising the president University on a
number of things I'm quite sure he's
heavily involved at this stage of how
are we going to get out of this so if
we're gonna bring T home bring him home
unless let's do our glass around him
with the people that he needs the
support that he needs because right now
it to your point we're an abject mess
and if we're going to stay home T
Martin's a great selection for that if
they're still trying to find someone out
there that's a tough one and what I mean
by out there is a sitting head coach has
had success elsewhere I think it's gonna
be hard to pry that person away from
their current state their current place
because why would you I think some of
those coaches may maneuver and get
better contracts where they are like
Gundy Mike Gundy that's a possibility
here's the thing Mike Gundy who I happen
to like a lot that built like four years
Tracy's career he's been in Oklahoma
State as either a player or a coach 23
out of left 26 years in Stillwater in
Stillwater he's got a major rivalry with
Oklahoma they don't beat Oklahoma that
often even though they're competing
better now than they ever have but
there's no serious outcry because he
doesn't beat Oklahoma consistently so
that's gonna be a problem for him and
his job in our place we have someone who
can compete with Nick Saban and beat him
and guess what
no one's done that in a long time we've
got to be able to be in our own state
now Vanderbilt never thought I'd ever
utter those words rich never thought I'd
utter those words we can't beat them
right now I mean this is it's a whole
different deal so I just don't know if
Mike Gundy is going to say to himself
after all those years in a really great
spot doing a fantastic job with
tremendous resources and money do I
really want to go take on that challenge
or there am i comfortable right here and
doing well with a chance most years to
compete for the big 12
I got a 38 key that'd be a key question
for okay I got you you know you're not
wrong man 30 seconds I have left with
you asking the poll question and we're
gonna reveal next segment Brockman we
might as well reveal it here all right
Charles Davis what's the best Bill
Murray comedy Caddyshack Ghostbusters
Groundhog Day stripes kingpin that we
know Chuck Pagano chooses to round hog
day what do you got well I go I go with
Caddyshack with him but I still think
rich that time that you were there with
Ivan Reitman of mike Mayock
and Mike and Michael dive in that
stripes fantastic right till you rolled
in the checkers defense all-timer I
remember when you told that story was on
the floor you laughed harder every time
you told the story I'd still have time
take care of yourself brother that's the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience